تراجع القوات الاسرائيليه من القراره وبنس
هيله كيف يمكن تفسيره اي دلالات يحمل في
ظل استمرار المعارك في جنوب
القطاع فيذا هناك عده دلالات قد يكون على
سبيل المثال الحصر يعني الضغوطات الخارجيه
اثنين تغيير الخطه العسكريه ثلاثه هنا
الاهم هو عدم القدره على تحقيق شيء
وبالتالي
يعمد الجيش الاسرائيلي الى اختيار الامكنه
الاقل دفاعا ومقاومه وبالتالي التركيز على
خانيونس من هنا راينا كثافه القصف على
محيط خانيونس حتى ايضا في الوسط على
الزويده يعني موقع الزويده هو على صلاح
الدين والرشيد بين الاثنين وهي في وسط
اربع مخيمات اساسيه وكانه هذه المنطقه هي
منطقه اساسيه وهذا يعيدنا الى ما قاله
قائد الفرقه 98 المظليين قال واليوم حسب
جريده اله اريتس يقول انه اننا نقاتل على
ليس 360 درجه
720 درجه وهي القتال مناورات فوق الارض
تحت الارض وهي كما المكعب روبريك يعني
المكعب المعقد هذا الامر يدل ان هناك
صعوبات كثيره يعني يواجهها الجيش
الاسرائيلي طيب عميد الياس رئيس هيئه
اركان ايضا تحدث عن ان المعركه معقده جيش
بهذا القدر وبهذا التجهيز العالي وبهذا
الدعم الغربي له بالاسلحه ما هي التعقيدات
التي
يواجهها
ا فقط لذكر ان مجله فوربز اليوم صنفت
الجيش
الاسرائيلي الرابع عشر في العالم في تصنيف
الجيوش
وهو يملك احدثه من الجيل الخامس يعني الاف
35 وحتى الميركافا 5 ولكن عندما ناخذ على
سبيل المثال فدا 300
365 م مربع لو اعتبرناها فارغه اسقطنا
عليها 500 م من الانفاق واسقط عليها
الابنيه والبنى التحتيه والطرقات و 2.2
مليون من السكان الاكثر كثافه في العالم
وعدنا اسقطنا عليها المقاومه التي حضرت
لفترات
طويله الانتاج العسكري التخطيط والاستعلام
هذا الامر ليس بالسهل ان يدخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى غزه و يعتبر على انها نزهه
ونفس الشخص يعني رئيس الاركان اعترف ان
الامر صعب امام من حضر نفسه لفتره 14 سنه
ولكن الهاجس الاكبر يبقى هو في الانفاق
جئت على ذكر الانفاق الجانب اسرائيلي تحدث
عن اكتشاف نفق وصور هذا النفق وصفه
بالطويل
والمعقد اهميه ما تم الكشف عنه من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي في ظل شبكه كبيره ومعقده
من
الانفاق كما قلت البارحه يعني الجيش
الاسرائيلي يخوض ثلاثه معارك الانفاق حرب
المدن وحرب البحث وجمع المعلومات عن
اليادات الفلسطينيه وعن الرهائن اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن هذا الامر هذا من الطبيعي
ان يكتشف لماذا لانه العمود الفقري
الاساسي لاستراتيجيه المقاومه تندرج تحت
الارض وكانه هناك مدينه غزه او قطاع غزه
مختلف اثنين الهاجس الاسرائيلي لقياس نجاح
معين يعتمد على هذه اكتشاف الانفاق وهو
خصص لها وحدات خاصه وقواعد اشتباك مهمه
اليوم اعلانها الامر وحتى دخول رئيس
الاركان الى بعض هذه الانفاق ليقول اننا
حققنا شيء ولكن هذا ليس ايضا يعني كما
يقال من الجمل اذنه هو ليس حتى الى هذه
المقياس 500 ر نتحدث عن 300 متر من
الانفاق هذا امر يعتبر ليس بالانجاز يبقى
مث سياتي بعد شكرا لك عميد الياس حناء
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
بيروت